[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is the fossilized egg of a giant dinosaur, a titanosaur.
When freshly laid, it would have weighed
around a kilo and a half, and it's shell
is about 2 millimeters thick.
While the eggs certainly were tough,
they still needed to be kept safe and warm.
So how did dinosaurs take care of their eggs?
In order to protect their eggs from predators
and to keep their eggs warm, dinosaurs
evolved a list of strategies.
One of these strategies was to build a nest
and then to actually sit on top of the nest.
We know certain dinosaurs did this
because we actually have fossils of dinosaurs
sat on top of nests.
Eggs found in these nests contain tiny babies
of the same species as the adults,
providing the first evidence that some dinosaurs looked
after their young.
But although this offered protection and shelter
from the elements, there was a downside
to incubating eggs in this way.
Having to sit on an egg and actually
look after it means that you are committed
to the care of that egg for the entire duration
of their development up until the point of hatching.
For some dinosaurs, it was a commitment worth making.
But others, like sauropods, faced a different challenge.
It's likely that some dinosaurs never sat on their eggs.
After all, many of these animals weighed tons and tons
and would simply have crushed them
before they had any chance of hatching.
So what was their solution?
There are some sauropod egg clutches
where the female excavated a long trench with her back feet.
She then backfilled the trench once she had laid all the eggs.
This behavior can be seen today.
Turtles bury their eggs to protect them from predators,
and the sun warmed sand keeps them at the ideal temperature.
But some dinosaurs had another trick to keep their eggs warm.
We think some dinosaur groups deliberately
collected and piled up rotting vegetation.
They basically formed a compost heap
on top of their egg filled nests.
Bush turkeys in Australia use this remarkable technique.
As the vegetation breaks down, it
releases enough heat to incubate their eggs for around seven
weeks.
But it was a discovery in 2010 that
revealed that some dinosaurs had an even more unusual way
of keeping their eggs warm.
They used heat from the Earth itself.
In one particular site in Argentina
that's had lots of sauropod egg discoveries,
it's right next door to some geothermal springs.
We're thinking the sauropods were
using that volcanic activity to help keep its eggs warm.
Another location, the Deccan region
of India, one of the most volcanic areas
during the late cretaceous, provides more evidence.
There are many, many layers of lava.
Then, in between the lava flows, we find dinosaur eggs.
Dinosaurs were coming to this location
even when it was highly active volcanically,
using it as a nesting site for literally centuries.
Dinosaurs had many ways to ensure their eggs would hatch,
but we can be certain of one thing--
their methods worked very effectively,
helping them to rule the world for over 150 million years.
[MUSIC PLAYING]